okay so um today we will discuss Putin's
plan to destroy the American Empire so
last class we discussed that uh Putin
loves his country
Russia and he believes that Western
consumerism has corrupted his nation and
he recognizes that U the source of
Western consumerism is the American
Empire so in order to completely free
its people
um he needs to destroy the Empire okay
and
historically Empires die when three
things happen concurrently okay together
the first is um over
extension and this is the main reason
why Empires die when they fight too many
wars at once and the reason why they're
overextended is H
hubis and what hubris is in military
strategy is the idea of
blindness so you are blind to the fact
of your own
limitations you are blind to the
strategy of your
opponents you are blind to the overall
geopolitical picture okay you're just
blind uh and the example is American
strategy nowadays where America is
fighting Russia and Ukraine where it is
fighting Hamas in Israel and there's a
threat of Iran on the
horizon but for whatever reason most
American policy makers believe that the
real threat is China we must prepare for
China in a Taiwan straight okay
eventually China will invade Taiwan and
we must be
ready right now this week America also
announc massive tariffs on Chinese
electrical
vehicles um and so America is engaged in
all these wars at once it's antagonizing
Russia Iran China at the same time and
so that's just
overextension because of
hubris okay
um second second way to kill an Empire
is
debt so the source of American power is
the US dollar remember that in 1945 um
Breton Woods there was an agreement that
the US dollar would become the reserve
currency of the world okay and the word
the phrase for that is exorbitant
privilege exorbitant privilege just
means that americ America has the right
to manufacture gold from nothing and the
world has to buy it because that's what
underpins global
trade okay but when you can do that what
happens eventually is that your nation
becomes fat lazy and
corrupt when money just falls off the
sky you're just used to boring money
okay so all America does right now is
print money and not make
money the problem with this is that
eventually the world is not going to
want to us want to use US Dollars
anymore because each time you use it
you're being taxed right by the
Americans and that's what bricks plus is
you may have heard of brics plus it is
an organization established initially by
uh Brazil Russia India China and sou
South Africa in order to create its own
Financial system to counter uh the US
Financial system but now there are more
countries that have joined
bricks um most prominently are Saudi
Arabia um and UAE and ban these
countries okay they're important because
they are the basis for the petrol dollar
remember that all US dollars US Dollars
can be used used to purchase oil and
that's why US dollar is worth a lot of
money okay so if these countries go to
breaks and opt out of the US Financial
system then basically this
American mountain of debt okay $ 35
trillion doll of debt comes crashing
down okay that's the second way to kill
an Empire and the Third
Way is Cil civil
descent or uh Eternal Discord Civil War
basically and so what we're seeing in
America right now is growing political
polarization okay between the left and
the right why this happens is that
people no longer
Believe The Binding
myths and stories that build a nation
okay nowadays young people no longer
believe that
America um is the source of good in this
world World an example why this is
happening is of course because Israel
right now is committing genocide in Gaza
right now Israel is attacking
RFA um and they're killing a lot of
children most people who are dying in
this war are children and America's not
doing anything to stop this in fact
America is the one who's providing
Israel with all the weapons so young
people are turning against the idea of
America as the good
Empire and um there's this amazing
statistic that one quarter of Young
Americans now believe that OS bin
ladin was a good guy okay and you know
when I grew up OS bin ladin was
considered Satan because he was the one
who was responsible for terrorism around
the world and for the 911 attacks okay
but this just shows you that the ideas
and the myths that B the country
together are falling apart and that's
what's causing the nation to fall apart
okay so the more overcommitted America
is the more Deb uh um it creates and the
more civil Discord it creates okay right
so this is how you kill an Empire when
all three things reach a Tipping Point
when it becomes too much the Empire dies
okay and the most likely outcome for
America is it goes into Civil War okay
it descends into Civil War and that's
something that I will discuss next class
all right so let's discuss how Putin is
doing this okay so the first thing that
Putin did was the Ukraine war right so
in February
2022 Putin invaded Ukraine and at that
time uh America was confident that three
things would happen Okay the first thing
that would happen is that Ukraine
would destroy the Russian army and and
perhaps even march to Moscow and
overthrow Putin okay we that at that
time that's what the news media was
reporting the Ukraine media was so much
stronger and more confident than the
Russian
forces second thing
was
that the Russian economy would be
destroyed why because America was
imposing
sanctions on uh Russia
so America it controls the Global
Financial system uh the ability to trade
America just basically sanctioned Russia
and said you are no longer allowed to
sell your oil on the black on on the
global market okay and the belief was
that this would cause Russia to collapse
overnight a lot of Western
multinationals left Russia and the
United States froze
300 billion dollars in Russian Assets in
US Banks okay so they thought that these
us the UN United States thought that
these sanctions would destroy the
Russian economy okay that's the second
thing that they thought would happen and
the third thing that that they would
happen was that it would make
NATO much stronger and more
united and it would make Russia into a
porah state meaning that no one would
want to ever associate with Russia again
okay so that was the argument back then
and today what what we have seen is that
the complete opposite has happened okay
so first of all um Russia has basically
won the war and it's won the war because
of attrition right Ukraine has lost
maybe
500,000 men in this war so they had no
more manpower if you don't have Manpower
you're not going to be able to fight
this war so this war has basically been
lost and Russia is dominant Russia has
basically achieved its main strategic
objectives which is basically the dones
region in uh eastern
Ukraine secondly not only has the
Russian economy not been destroyed but
it's been doing extremely well okay and
the reason why is that ultimately all
economies China
India
Europe um Africa Middle East they all
need resources in order for their
economies to work you need oil you need
food and Russia has a lot of oil and
food and that's why countries have been
going to Russia and making side deals
okay also Russia has been transitioning
to a war economy so its manufacturing
base has been increasing so overall the
economy has been doing a lot better okay
us sections have not been working the
third of all NATO has become more
divided less and less United why because
Germany um which is the most powerful
country in Europe right now it's complet
it's completely dependent on Russian
resources to F its
economy that's how the German economy
works it's a manufacturing economy it
Tak cheap Russian gas manufactures it
into cars and sells it to China okay but
the United States blew up the
northstream pipeline okay blew up the
northstream pipeline which connected uh
gas which basically delivered gas from
Russia to Germany and it's imposing a
trade war on China so basically the
German economy is about to collapse and
Germans are very angry uh about this
so the Ukraine war has been a tremendous
success for
Putin and it's really shown that America
is a paper
tiger and it's also creating a lot of
civil dis descent in America because the
majority of Americans are asking the
question why are we giving Ukraine
hundreds of billions of dollars when our
people don't even have health insurance
our people are suffering and we're
giving Ukraine hundreds of billions of
dollars okay the other thing that um
this Ukraine war has exposed is that the
American Empire is overextended and what
I mean by that is that in order to give
Ukraine weapons what America is doing is
basically taking weapon systems from in
Japan in South Korea and other places
and giving it to Ukraine okay so America
is not manufacturing more weapons it's
just taking other weapon systems it has
elsewhere and moving to Ukraine so
America is badly ere extended okay and
of course by uh giving all this money to
Ukraine it's causing American debt to go
up and after Ukraine loses War this debt
will be gone okay because Ukraine cannot
pay it back okay so but after the
Ukraine war what happened next was on
October 7th of last last year remember
that Hamas launched an attack on Israel
that killed about about a thousand
people and Israel responded by attacking
Gaza and by doing this this has helped
Putin and has hurt the United States
okay uh mainly by first of
all uh
diminishing American Prestige right
because America right now is helping
Israel commit genocide so the entire
world is basically turning against
America even the young people in America
are turning against America you know
these college protests in America they
will only expand in the fall
okay and the other problem is that
America it's America has shown it cannot
control Israel in fact people say that
Israel Now controls
America and the third thing is that that
this war threatens to explode throughout
the Middle East okay um at any point
Iran can enter the battle hesah can
enter the the battle from the north okay
so it's it's a it's a powder
keg uh it's it's it's a like a lake of
gasoline about to be lit on fire so
America is um badly um Extended okay
so and you can make the argument
that either
Putin knew about the Hamas attack or
even encouraged the attack okay because
the main winner of this Hamas attack is
obviously Vladimir Putin and the loser
is America okay so does this make sense
so far all right so um let's talk about
the future or what of predictions moving
forward so if it is true that Putin's
intention is to destroy the American
Empire by focusing on these three
fundamental weaknesses in the Empire and
if it is true that he start the Ukraine
war um to
further the det deterioration of the
Empire if he is the one who is abetting
Hamas then we can predict that Putin
will continue to do certain things okay
the first thing that he will do as he
will drag on the Ukraine
war so he will not end it he will not
seek peace he will not negotiate peace
terms he will continue to drag it on
okay why would he do
that why not just declare Victory or why
why not just negotiate peace why would
he want to drag it on
okay yeah the Russian people will be at
War but then the question then is why
would he drag it on and not expand it
right he wants to drag it on but he
doesn't want to expand it expand it
means he attacks Poland okay he doesn't
want to do that he just wants to drag it
on
why yeah okay so the real the reason is
that
Ukraine is turning out to be a black
hole for NATO NATO and the United States
is pouring in all this money
weapons and
Manpower and it's just losing it all
okay so in other words
Ukraine is a battlefield to increase
American debt and create civil Discord
among NATO and America okay Germany does
not want to fight this war Germany wants
out
you understand so as long as this war
keeps on going uh it's going to create
more friction between NATO and United
States and that's what Putin wants but
if Putin attacks Poland then all of NATO
is forced to fight him okay does that
make sense so he does not want to expend
the war he he just wants the war to
maintain the status quo and for it to
drag on okay so that's the first
prediction second is that
um to control the situ Ukraine he needs
America to fight another War okay he
needs to distract America and the
distraction will be Iran remember how
for the past few classes we've been
discussing how America wants to attack
Iran and Iran wants revenge against
America okay but for this to happen What
Putin needs to do is talk to Iran and
guarantee that Iran will be protected by
the Russian nuclear umbrella which means
that America will not be allowed to use
nuclear weapons when it invades Iran
because Putin will respond with nuclear
weapons of his own okay does that make
sense so as long as Putin comes to an
agreement with Iran and say that I will
use my nuclear weapons to protect you
from US nuclear weapons then Iran will
take the initiative and start to provoke
America into a wider war and again there
are many ways IR can do that okay it can
use hollah to attack Israel um it can
expand its nuclear program it can
disrupt Red Sea shipping okay there are
there are lots of ways that Iran can use
to provoke America into a for scale
Invasion which is what Putin wants all
right um North
Korea
so
as United States becomes distracted in
Ukraine and Iran North Korea can now
take the initiative right because um
what North Korea can do is threaten to
invade South Korea and there about
30,000 US troops in South Korea so North
Korea doesn't actually have to do
anything but the threat of North Korea
will force America to to divert
resources to South Korea does that make
sense okay and this will probably even
have to force North uh South Korea
United States to start to bribe North
Korea okay and we can expect that North
Korea does this because put has given
North Korea his assurance that he will
protect North Korea in in in the event
of a war okay does that make sense all
right
bricks we will see
bricks continue expand okay we'll also
see bricks maybe formally announce a new
currency or a new trading system to
counteract the American Le system now
what people have said is that bricks is
not
capable of replacing the US dollar and
that is true okay but remember that
bricks doesn't doesn't have to actually
replace the US dollar it can only it it
just has to threaten because a lot of
finance a lot of money it's just
confidence okay you have the US dollar
because you're confident that it's
valuable but once you lose the
confidence in US dollar you will no
longer want to use it okay does that
make sense and um the last thing is
to maintain close relationships to to
main maintain a very close relationship
with
China so Putin will come to China more
often and he and cing ping will hug each
other more okay they might even kiss one
day who knows okay but and again listen
the reality is if you look at Game
Theory there are lots of geopolitical
differences between Russia and China
much more so than between China and
United States but again and Putin
doesn't actually need China to do
anything all Putin needs is for China
not to work United States okay because
in this situation one way that the
United States can survive or protect its
Empire is by working with China right to
triangulate against Russia does that
make sense so as long as China remains
neutral then Russia and Putin can
continue to exert pressure on the
American Empire
okay so over the next three to four
years we should see all these things
happen Okay so first thing is the
Ukrainian War does not end Putin will
find a way for it to drag on but
actually expanding okay that's the first
thing second thing is
Iran um takes the initiative against
United States third thing is North Korea
starts being becoming much more
belligerent against South Korea and
Japan forcing America to focus more
attention in East
Asia breaks will continue continue to
expand uh and then the putting
relationship with CP will continue to
Blossom okay does that make sense all
right any questions so far before I
continue excuse
me okay that's a good question so why
would America want China's help okay the
first thing is you have an overe
extension problem okay you don't want to
be fighting too many wars at once so you
come to a peace with China you don't
have to worry about East Asia anymore
because the real threat from Americans
perspective is that China invades
Taiwan okay that's the first
thing second thing is that China is a
major buyer of US dollars because
because of its trade with America and
because China buys a lot of oil right
you want China to keep on buying US
dollars so you can sustain the debt okay
does that make sense and Third of all
there are a lot of geopolitical
conflicts between Russia and
China if you think about it Russia is
more more of a threat to China uh than
the United States is okay does that make
sense historically Russia and trying to
fought Wars uh many wars over the
Border Okay so
if you um become friends with China then
Putin needs to take take the defensive
and focus more on protecting the Russia
China border does that make sense
because right now Putin can just focus
on the offensive but if China is on the
side of the United States then putting
is force on the defensive okay does that
make sense okay any more any more
questions yeah Peter
Rec that's right that's right that's
right so basically what's been happening
is China is now no longer
buying uh US Dollars and it's TR it's
transferring its US Dollars into gold
okay so China is encouraging everyone to
buy gold don't buy any more US Dollars
guys buy
gold right and the reason why is because
America's debt is a huge problem for
America and the only way for America to
sustain its debt is if China continues
to buy US debt okay does that make sense
okay but but but that's but that's a
great Point Peter any more questions
before I
continue
Rel okay so um Jack asked a great
question all right um it makes sense for
you for China and United States to be
friends right because China exports a
lot of Commodities to the United States
the United States is a huge Market
United States also provides China with a
lot of Technology right
um and Jack asked a question why would
China want to be friends with Russia and
the answer is because China right now
feels threatened by the United States
okay the United States uh is launching
an economic war against
China and um if you look at a map
okay um China is surrounded by US
military bases and the problem is that
that China needs Imports of oil and food
to sustain its economy does that make
sense so if America ever launches a
embargo against China China
collapses okay so in other words China
needs to open up new trade routs and the
only way and the best partner right now
is Russia because it has a lot of access
to energy and and oil okay so um right
now the situation in China is that
Chinese policy makers know that the
situation in China is terrible the
economy has collapsed demographics has
collapsed um China is completely
dependent on the world for oil and food
okay China is extremely vulnerable right
now if America says says to the world
China is our enemy then China has no
choice but to find a new friend and
unfortunately the only friend that China
has right now is Russia okay does that
make sense okay so um but but look I
mean the geopolitical situation for
China it's really really bad okay right
any more questions before I
continue okay so Selen asked a great
question why does uh the United States
think that China will attack Taiwan and
the answer is that America is always
looking to start new Wars okay it has
something called the military-industrial
complex and America is always fighting
Wars so to justify all this defense
spending um it needs to find new enemies
and um it believes that the greatest
threat to the American Empire right now
is China even though by the way there's
no evidence this is the case okay right
now the relationship between United
States and China is China sends America
a lot of cheap goods and the US gives
China a lot of US Dollars okay so
basically what's happening is that the
Communist party is storing the wealth of
the Chinese people in American Banks
this is a great deal for both America
Wall Street and the Chinese Communist
party okay so there's no reason for
these countries to be conf with each
other but unfortunately the American
policy makers always need an enemy to
justify the incredible amount of money
they spend on defense okay does that
make sense okay any more questions
before I
continue excuse
me I I didn't understand the question
can can you repeat that
oh that's a great question so what
happens if China takes over Taiwan what
does America lose and the answer is like
not that much okay you make the argument
that Taiwan has a semiconductor industry
but guess what you can move that
semiconductor industry
elsewhere okay for America it's just
want to face you understand America
doesn't really lose anything if China
takes over Taiwan
but for America it's the Empire it has
hubris and therefore it must say
face right does that make sense all
right all right
so this is Putin's plan to destroy the
um American Empire and so the question
then is well this makes Putin in this
makes Putin a
genius so how he's able to do this and
the argument I want I want I want to
make to you today is that for many
reasons Russian leaders have a strategic
imagination they just think
differently and more strategically than
anyone else okay and so the example I
want to use is Joseph
Stalin because we know actually know a
lot about Joseph Stalin all right so
let's look at the world in 1939
9 and in 1939 there are about six Global
Powers okay there's Russ there's Soviet
Union
okay there's
Japan there's United States there's UK
Britain the British Empire Germany and
France okay so this is the map of the
world in
1939 now let's talk about each country
United States is far away and it's
neutral it does not like to get involved
in the Affairs of Europe but it's
suffering from the Great Depression it's
economy has
collapsed okay Japan the Japanese empire
is a war machine but the problem for
Japan is that it is completely reliant
on Imports okay it needs oil for its
Empire its War Machine and there only
two sources of of oil close by
there's the Soviet Union Far East and
then there's southeast Asia okay now
Japan is getting most of its oil from
the United States but the United States
is angry at Japan why is United States
angry at Japan do you guys
know exactly okay because Japan invaded
China and the United States doesn't want
that okay so it's very likely that the
United States will eventually cut off
all exports to Japan
and so Japan has a choice you can either
invade here or you can invade here but
that's those are your two choices okay
that's that's Japan you can either invo
the Soviet Union or southeast Asia okay
um the Soviet Union is a communist
country and for the past 20 30 years
it's been trying extremely hard to
industrialize but it's hard to
industrialize because first of all no
one wants to trade with the Soviet Union
okay so it's so they can't get any
resources
um the Soviet Union is still very much
an
agricultural uh nation and the Soviet
Union doesn't really have that much
technology and expertise okay it doesn't
really have that much human capital so
Soviet Union is a huge country it's a
world's largest country it's an Empire
but in terms of manufacturing and
Technology it's behind the West okay now
in Europe there are three nations you
have France Germany and the
UK the UK is an Empire higher okay it
has colonies all around the world uh
Germany Lost World War I and so it has
to pay all these reparations to UK and
France okay and now Hitler is in power
and Hitler is determined to reunite
Germany okay because Germany lost a lot
of land because of World War I okay so
he wants to reunite greater Germany okay
that's his ambition it's not to conquer
the world it's to reunite
Germany all right and then you have
France um which is the weakest of all
these Powers but it still has an
Empire okay so looking at a map in
1939 and we use Game Theory what should
be happening or what should happen maybe
five years from now 1945 okay let's
let's let's use Game Theory to map out
what what what should be happening or
what will happen
given this map and given the individual
players the interests of these different
nations what do you expect to
happen who does everyone
hate who does everyone
hate who does everyone want to like go
invade
why why does everyone want to invade
this
Union okay yes first of all it has a lot
of resources and it's not that strong
okay that's the first reason but there's
actually a better reason why everyone
wants to attack the Soviet Union
why what's happening internally in the
United States right now the the Great
Depression what ideology is a threat to
the American
government communism okay do you
understand so there's a global communist
movement in 1930s that's very very
powerful in fact in 1930s and you guys
don't know this but America was on the
break of Revolution okay the Communist
could have any time took over America if
America failed to stop the economic
bleeding that was happening all right so
everyone was afraid of Communism Japan
would have loved to invade Soviet Union
because Japan hates
communism and Soviet Union has all of
oil right so Here Comes Japan Germany
would love to destroy the Soviet Union
because Nazis hated who the
most who did Nazis hate the mo hate who
the
most why did they hate
Jews what what did Hitler believe about
Jews uh okay they control the word ofcy
but there there's actually a better
reason why he hated Jews what what's the
problem with
Jews okay you guys don't know this but
they all Communists okay Hitler thought
that all Jews were Communists so Hitler
hated first and foremost communism
okay Nazism hated communism the
most so Hitler wanted to invade the
Soviet Union how about French in the
UK how about French in the
UK what did they want to do what did
they who who do they
hate Russia right Soviet Union United
States sure why not okay do you
understand so 1945 if we use Game Theory
okay we should have
expected that soet Union would have been
partition into different countries okay
these Powers would have invaded the
country together and colonized the
Soviet Union and destroyed the threat of
global communism once and for all okay
doesn't make sense but that's not going
to happen happen right that's not what
happen what happened was that in
1939 Hitler invaded Poland okay and when
the moment that Hitler invaded
Poland France and Britain declared war
on
Germany and then Germany defeated France
and Britain okay Britain was forced to
return to its to um its Island but
Churchill refused to seek peace with
Hitler in fact Hitler tried to seek
peace with Churchill seven times and
each time Churchill was like go to hell
we're going to fight this war till the
end why was chch so angry at
Hitler what happened
because Germany destroyed the British
army right it's a complete loss of fa
for the British Empire so church was
very very angry at Hitler and Churchill
refused to ever negotiate with Hitler in
fact Hitler sent this Emissary called
Rudolph H to Britain to Scotland to
negotiate a truce and church just put
him in prison
okay um but what's the irony of all this
Germany invades Poland what does Germany
invade Poland do do you guys
know have you guys study this history
okay it's it's because of something
called the
molotov rippen trop uh
P so this was an agreement between the
Soviet Union and Germany to partition
Poland into two do you understand so
Germany and Soviet Union invaded Poland
together Soviet Union the Soviet Union
attacked from the East and the Germans
attack from the west but what happened
was Britain and France declared war in
Germany but not the Soviet Union okay
that's pretty clever of Silent don't you
think in fact you can make the
argument
that if this thing was not signed Hitler
would not have attacked
Poland okay and the reason why is the
other thing about this pact is that
Soviet Union agreed to give Germany
resources for its war machine oil and
food and other uh inputs okay does that
make sense because remember the Soviet
Union has to Ukraine which produce a lot
of food and oil okay does that make
sense all right next thing that happened
was that in June 1941
operation
Barbarosa so Hitler invades the Soviet
Union okay and if you read history
anyone will tell you that this operation
bar Barosa was a tremendous success for
Germany and a strategic failure for for
Soviet Union it was a grave mistake
strategic blunder for Stalin okay what
did Stalin do wrong well first of all
he refused to defend the
Border okay there were 45 million Soviet
troops at the border defending Soviet
Union but they were given direct orders
to not to not to not sorry given direct
orders not to provoke the Germans you
understand the Germans fire you don't
fire back and because of this order a
the German army which which about three
to four million was able to overrun the
border and almost reach Moscow okay that
was a grave mistake on the part of
Stalin second is that Stalin ignored
intelligence okay there was a lot of
intelligence that said that Germany was
going to invade the Soviet Union how
could you hide the fact that you have 4
million troops assembled to attack the
Soviet Union okay so there's a lot of
intelligence going to Stalin and tell
silin hey the Germans are coming and S
said nope I refuse to believe this
intelligence in fact you had German
soldiers desert the German Army swim
across the river to the Soviet side and
tell the Soviets Hey My My My comrades
the entire Army is about to attack you
and the Soviets shot these German
soldiers because they F these German
soldiers were
spies okay so Stalin
ignored intelligence the third thing
that son did was before the outbreak of
War he purged the Red Army the Soviet
Army of its leadership of generals okay
so the top generals of the Soviet Army
the Red Army were all dead or in prison
because Stalin got rid of them for not
being politically loyal enough okay
and but the fourth thing is why is why
did s do this and the answer is what
historians will tell you is that Stalin
trusted
Hitler okay this was the ultimate
mistake that Stalin made Stalin believed
Hitler was his friend he believed that
Hitler would never invade
him okay and so this is what you're
taught
in history class when you go to the
United States um you'll be taught this
when you go on the internet you'll be
taught this okay this is completely
wrong this analysis is completely wrong
all right so we're going to use Game
Theory to understand why this is wrong
all right so using Game Theory let's
let's look at four possible scenarios
okay scenario a
is Soviets attack first
and they encircle
Berlin second SC is soviet's
attack okay and they're stopped at the
border scenario C is Soviets attack
sorry Germans
attack and the Soviets stopped them okay
and S Ste is Germans
attack and they reach Moscow okay which
is actually what happened all right so
these are four possible different
scenarios that could have happened in
June 1941 all right remember that there
were four to five million Soviet troops
at the border okay what were they doing
there they were about to attack
Germany the Soviets had a plan to attack
Germany but the Germans struck first
okay so let's look at these four
possible scenarios and see what happens
first scenario is the Soviets attacked
Germany first and they reach Berlin what
happens
now what happens
now what do all what do all the other
countries
do yes do you understand Stalin reaches
Berlin boom Japan comes from the East
Russia Britain comes to the aid of of
Germany United States comes to the aid
of Britain all the world unites against
the Soviet Union okay
so what would happen in this
war the Soviet Union loses this war do
you understand okay now let's look at B
the Soviets invade but the Germans sto
them at the border okay now what
happens no one
happens yeah so Japan still invades okay
um and Britain starts to negotiate with
Germany and seek a peace because Britain
cannot afford for the Soviet Union to
overrun Germany because all because then
communism takes over Europe does that
make sense okay so in B we can't say
that Chan would lose but they would not
win the war okay you understand so B is
not that good either now let's look at C
the Germans attack and the Soviets hold
at the border now what
happens now what
happens they just destroy each other
right United States Britain Japan
they're all laughing they're like oh
they're just killing each other who
cares not not our problem okay but now
let's look at situation D where the
Germans attack and they are about to
destroy the Soviet Union what happens
now
the other countries have to come and
help the Soviet Union why why why why is
it the United States and Britain must
come to help the Soviet Union
why what what would happen if Germany
takes over the Soviet
Union that's right okay they take over
the resources therefore they take over
the world you understand because Germany
has technology it has military power but
it lacks resources ources you combine
the resources with the German military
they're Invincible now the United States
will be forever shut out of the world
Germany will not invade the United
States but the United States could never
ever attack Germany again does that make
sense so what happens is the after the
Soviets invade uh sorry after the
Germans invade and the Soviet Army is
destroyed America immediately gives the
Soviet Union a of Aid okay it's what we
call land Le from 1941 to
1945 America gave $200 billion to S
Union for free okay it gave weapons
resources technology and food basically
what America did was industrialize the
Soviet Union does that make sense that's
what America did Soviet Union could not
industrialize by itself but America
helped Soviet Union to industrialize
let's look at Lenley okay weapons
America gave the S Union onethird of all
ammunition used in the war onethird of
all explosives one half of all aircraft
14,000
airplanes one half all tanks 13,000
tanks okay resources America gave oil
and food 80% of all copper 55% of of
aluminum of aluminum and steel okay
technology America gave the Soviet Union
radio technology radio communications
railroad Transportation heavy industry
and lots and lots of food okay in other
words America basically built the Soviet
Union in heavy industry for it okay does
that make sense and also at the end of
the day what Soviet can do is reverse
engineer all this technology and build
its own initiatory does that make sense
okay so then really turn the Soviet
Union into a
superpower and sing could get all this
for free because America could not
afford for the Soviet Union to lose the
war okay what's the other benefit of
having the Germans attack first and
almost destroy Moscow what's the other
benefit and S really needed this this
actually more important than l
which is
what national Unity right now all the
Soviets were United in the fight against
Nazi
Germany before Comm communism was
tearing the country apart there was a
Civil War the rich people all fled the
country right but now because the
Germans were in were invading the entire
country was United against German
Germany this is what they call the Great
Patriotic War they were fighting this
war for the love of their country the
love of Mother Russia okay so and what
turned the war was the will to
fight
the the Russian the Russians lost 26
million people in the war that's a lot
of people but by losing this many people
it made the entire nation
refused to surrender they had the will
to fight okay much more so than the
Germans does that make sense okay so in
history you're taught that operation
Barbarosa proved that stellin was not a
strategic
genius that he was played by Hitler but
if you just do game through
analysis this was the best possible
outcome for the s un okay in 1939 the
world should have United against Soviet
Union but what happened was the world
United against Nazi Germany and gave
Soviet Union the technology the money
and the resources to become a global
superpower right doesn't make sense and
because Soviet Union became a global
superpower it was able to turn China
into a communist country does that make
sense if so the Soviet Union did not
become a global superpower with all this
heavy
industry then China would not become a
communist power M would not have won the
war
okay so in other words all this is
telling us is that Stalin is a
genius he turned a losing War into a
winning
War okay so last thing I want to do is
okay
fine how was Salin able to do this what
makes the Russian imagination different
from the Western
imagination okay so I would I would say
three
things the first thing is just
intuition and intuition means that Putin
and Stalin they're able to read the
political winds okay they able to sense
the mood of the world the German word
for this is Ze guys okay Spirit of the
times but they're able to
sense the mood of the world okay put in
NOS that the American Empire is about to
die and so he feels embolden to act okay
so it's intuition second is
Imagination so Putin and Son both have a
strategic imagination which means like
okay they sense these winds but they can
also Imagine hey
if I did this how would these winds
change okay that's an imagination to
able to predict or imagine the
future and the last thing which is the
strangest of all is multiple
personalities meaning that Putin and S
are such brilliant men that they embody
multiple personalities in them and
that's why they're so
unpredictable all right so the example
is
this everyone says that Stalin trusted
Hitler so Hitler played Stalin but if
you just look at if you just analyze the
game okay the then the conclusion is
silent
played Hitler you understand Hitler did
everything that s wanted him to do
Hitler invaded Poland which caused
German which caused France and Britain
declare war on him okay then Hitler
attacked Soviet Russia which brought
America into the
war and help the Soviet Union become an
Empire you understand so Hitler was
completely played by stad and the answer
is so the question then is how right
because in 1941 June
1941 Hitler did not have to invade
Soviet Union okay he could have waited
for St to invade him then the opposite
would have happened right then America
would have joined the war on Hitler's
behalf and they would have defeated the
Soviet Union okay so what convinced
Hitler to do the most insane thing and
invade Russia first
and the answer
is Hitler trusted Stalin does that make
sense all right so imagine this Hitler
and Salin they're having drinks okay
they're both drunk and they're on the
porch and they're staring at the
mountains and the moon okay and salon
and Hitler are talking and all Sal has
to do is say three words and then Hitler
is like I'm I'm I'm GNA come invade you
what are these three words
how can sing get Hitler to
invade Russia what are the three words
that Salin can
say to
Hitler I trust
you okay I Joseph Stalin trust you out
of Hitler I don't trust anyone I don't
trust my own mother but I choice you
Hitler okay then why would Hitler invade
exactly okay because Hitler thinks now
that Salin is EAS Target as Shaq says
Sal Salin is a sheep I Hitler am a lion
I am a wolf you're are a sheep therefore
I eat you you understand
okay and but Stalin could only need to
do this if he had multiple
personalities okay St had to be a sheep
in front of Hitler he couldn't pretend
he had to
be does that make
sense okay so this is these three
things are the Russian
strategic imagination the ability to
feel the political Winds of the moment
the ability to prophesize and predict
the ability to be multiple individuals
at
once and that's how Stalin was able to
win World War II and this is why Putin
will be able to destroy the American
Empire okay any
questions okay so s asked the most
important question okay why the Russians
different okay all right so the problem
isn't Russia the problem is us the West
okay so when we talk about the west
Western thinking it comes from British
thinking and there are three distinct
characteristics of British thinking
that's different from Russian thinking
okay right let's look at British
philosophy versus Russian philosophy all
right okay the first major difference is
that British philosophy tends to be
narrow whereas Russia tends to be
broad Okay the reason why is Britain is
an island therefore it FS very narrowly
about the world whereas Russia it's a
huge country it's the world's largest
country therefore it thinks very broadly
about the world and to understand the
difference what you do is you read
British
literature and compare it with Russian
literature okay Russian literature you
have Leo Toy Story WR War and Peace and
a Korean okay these are very huge epics
and then um British literature you have
J Austin Thomas Hardy they're great okay
but they're very narrow in their focus
so that's a big first big difference
second big big difference
is British philosophy believes in the
idea of empiricism
okay empirism is a philosophy de
developed by British philosopher like
David Hume and the idea is we can only
know what we
experience we can only know what we
see okay so in another word for empirism
is the idea of skepticism be
skeptical of abstract philosophy
okay because we can never know it for
example you can never never really
understand mathematics because
mathematics is beyond your experience
okay you can only know what you
experience okay and it's true but it's
very but it limits your imagination
okay the Russians believe in
mysticism okay so they're they're very
spiritual religious
people so there are forces we don't
understand there are individuals who are
prophets who are sent to us by God we
can never know who who they are we can
never know how they think but we just
have to believe that's the case Okay so
the Russians are going to be much more
mystical in their thinking than the
British are
okay and the last thing
is the British believe in logic okay
like it's like mathematics you can go
from one to two 2 to 3 to four to five
okay everything has to be logical
everything has to be connected
together whereas the Russians they
believe in
intuition okay you can
jump you can imagine things you don't
have to be logical whereas the British
say you have to be logical and these
three ideas neuro empirism and logic
they created the
Western mind of today
okay so this is what dominates in
Academia so when you go off to
University they expect you to think in
this way narrow empirical and
logical okay and if you think about it
this is perfect if you want to build a
bureaucracy right this is bureaucratic
thinking this is the
bureaucratization of the
imagination okay you're not allowed to
say things without evidence and logic
and experience okay and the Russians
don't have this so they can do this all
right now there's obviously more good
things about the system than about this
system but the problem with the British
system is like no great man could ever
arise from W Society does that make
sense because all this creates a process
orientated systemized bureaucratic style
of
thinking okay so for
example I give this talk right I could
never give this talk in America or
Britain because they all think I'm
crazy okay does that make sense they're
like What's your evidence for
this wait are you
refuting Decades of scholarship about
World War
II are you telling me that Stalin was a
genius when no one thought he was a
genius how dare you
refute these thousands of Scholars who
have put all this work into World War II
scholarship okay do you
understand all right so in the British
system no one like Putin can
arise but in the Russian system someone
like Stalin and Putin can arise the
problem though is that what happens if
you don't have pu Putin or Stalin well
then you're you're you're then this
system this system becomes very weak
okay does that make sense okay so the
British system doesn't really need great
leaders but the Russian system you do
need great leaders and if you are a
great leader then you're allowed to
completely follow your intuition and
Imagination to do great things like
Joseph Stalin in World War II and what
Putin is doing today okay does that make
sense okay any more
questions oh that's a great question
okay so last semester we said the Greeks
and um the the
Greeks are more like the Russians than
they are like the
British okay so um the Russian system
the Greek system it's a much more
natural human
system okay and the British system
basically it's trying to remove
intuition and Imagination from the
decision-making process from the
intellectual process because intuition
and Imagination are too
mysterious okay so in other words okay
let's just say that I'm Joseph Stalin in
World War II okay
1939 for me to execute my plan I need to
write a me Memo detailing my thinking
okay now obviously I can't do that
because if I did that um first of all I
couldn't execute my plan but second it
would confuse everyone like like like
what are you trying to do again okay do
you do you
understand okay and so so the Greeks
believed in imagination intuition as
well okay but not the
British and we live in the British
system okay all right
any more
questions okay so Jack asked a good
question okay um how like how much did
the Greeks influence the British and the
answer is not very not that much because
remember like after the Greeks came the
Romans the Romans were like this and
there was a Romans who influenced the
British who then influenced Americans
okay so we're living basically in a
Roman world as opposed to a Greek
world right does that make
sense okay any more
questions um
so
um um this is a really hard question
okay what influences Russia well I mean
what the Russians will say is that
they're Christian Nation that they come
from a Christian n Christian tradition
and the Christian tradition comes from a
Greek tradition
okay okay does that make
sense so Christianity um
Christianity they would say that
Christianity uh is the main influence
okay and there there are some Greek
elements to Christianity what the
Russians say is that their Christianity
is a more Pure or more ancient form form
of Christianity okay we remember like
when we study the when stud Christianity
Christianity changed over the centuries
right so basically this is a pre
Augustine Christianity okay before
Augustine any more
questions okay great so um uh next class
we do the American Civil War okay